Speaker 1: We've been doing a lot of coverage
of this Texas GOP convention that occurred over
the weekend. Just coincidentally, a lot of
wild stuff happened at it. And one of those
things was the organization of gay Republicans
called the Log Cabin Republicans got banned
from having a booth at the convention, so they
were no longer allowed to show up at as an
organization. Obviously, I'm sure individuals
could have still gone, but because they
represented a gay representation organization,
they were not allowed to set up their
normal booth. A group of Texas Republicans who
represent conservatives and the LGBTQ community
said they were denied the ability to set up a
booth at the Texas Republican Party Convention.
The Log Cabin Republicans of Fort Worth, a
chapter of the National Log Cabin Republicans
Organization, said they were not allowed to set
up a booth at the convention, which took place
in Houston over the weekend and featured several
Republican organizations and vendors. The Fort
Worth Star-Telegram reported the move prompted a
comment from the national Log Cabin Republicans,
whose president called the decision narrow minded.
It's clear that inclusion wins, which makes the
Texas Republican Party leadership's decision to
exclude the Texas Log Cabin Republicans from the
convention not just narrow minded, but politically
shortsighted, President Charles Moran said in a
statement citing former President Donald Trump's
support of the LGBTQ Republicans. So that Charles.
His name is Rand. It just doesn't say more on
Moran is correct that this is narrow minded
and short sighted by the Republican Party. But it
bothers me because even though in this situation,
I don't at all think that his organization should
have been banned from participating in that event.
He should have known that that's the party
he's been supporting for all of these years.
He and his organization do this shameful thing
where they give legitimacy to the outrageous
claims that the right makes about the LGBTQ
community by. You know, they bolster it by.
Also reciprocating those claims. But I'm an LGBTQ
person so I can get away with it is what they
do. And it's like, you should have known
that the party you're standing behind,
the party that you advocate on behalf of, does
not stand for a world where you are included.
And you should have expected this to happen
eventually. You spew these lies and hate about
the community that you're a part of. Eventually,
they're going to come for you, too. And it's just
super fascinating, I guess, to give some leeway
to the organization because. Gay marriage.
Was legalized. There was this little moment,
if you all remember, where it seemed like
maybe the Republican Party was going to talk
less about the LGBTQ type stuff and pretend
to be a little bit inclusive. If you remember,
Trump literally said multiple times that he was
a pro-gay president or whatever, maybe not
pro-gay, but an ally of the community. But then
somewhat recently they just turn the dial back
to 11 and are focusing all of their hatred on
LGBTQ Americans. So while the party shouldn't
exclude this group, of course, from being a part
of their conventions, a part of the party, the Log
Cabin Republicans shouldn't have been supporting
this party for all of these years. And this is.
The chickens coming home to roost. Unfortunately,
you can't join a party that is actively
working to erase your existence and then
claiming your existence is bad and wrong,
and then making your existence the center
point of their hateful platform. And then be
surprised whenever they turn their backs on you.
If you want to hear more of what I have to say
on issues like this, don't forget to subscribe
to my YouTube channel where I drop videos
daily. You can find that by going to Luke
Beasley on YouTube, or if you're watching
this on YouTube or listening to the podcast,
there will be a link in the description you
can click and I'll take you to my channel.
You can also listen to my show as a podcast on any
podcast listening platform. We'll be right back.